no this is not the time simply to end  the lockdown this week instead we're  taking the first careful steps to modify  our measures and the first step is a  change of emphasis that we hope that  people will act on this week we said  that you should work from home if you  can and only go to work  if you must we now need to stress that  anyone who can't work from home for  instance those in construction or  manufacturing should be actively  encouraged to go to work and we want it  to be safe for you to get to work so you  should avoid public transport if at all  possible because we must and will  maintain social distancing and  capacity will therefore be limited so  work from home if you can but you should  go to work if you can't work from home  and to ensure you're safe at work we've  been working to establish new guidance  for employers to make workplaces couvade  secure and when you do go to work if  possible do so by car or even better by  walking or bicycle